Speaker 1: Let's go next to Joseph from Tucson.
Joseph, you're on the air.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Hi.
I just had a question where given the amount
of just totally unprecedented events that
we've seen over the past couple of years,
yeah.
What to even be very accurate to use
Speaker 2: assessments from precedent when
thinking about something like the
Speaker 4: midterms in 2022?
Speaker 1: I think you're making a good point,
which is we make all of these historical analyzes
typically after, you know, it's sort of like
in baseball where they say, you know,
Speaker 5: the the Orioles in the seventh
and
Speaker 1: eighth innings in day games played
after September, they tend to hit 400 with
runners in scoring position.
And it's like, OK, does that historical analysis
really tell us anything actionable or substantive
about today?
And things are so wacky and different right
now?
We have a question mark around like all those
Trumpists that were activated by Trump.
Do they care about the midterms?
Are they going to vote
Speaker 2: all of these different things?
So I think it's
Speaker 1: fair to ask the question.
I still do think that things are lining up
very much as they have historically, which
is Democrats took the White House in 2020.
It's not looking good for Democrats in the
House of Representatives in 2022.
I think a lot of those historical things are
Speaker 2: plausible
Speaker 1: in terms of the next election cycle
or two, but you're right that we always have
to say, Well, what's different this time?
It might not all be the same.
Speaker 4: All right, well, very interesting.
Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 2: Great to hear from ERA.
Speaker 1: There's Joseph from Tucson.
Why don't we go next to Tobias from Germany?
Tobias from Germany.
You're on the air.
Speaker 6: Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
Yes, I can.
I great.
I have two
Speaker 2: questions.
Speaker 6: The first one is that many your
opinion about freedom of speech, because when
I look at a complete situation, I think that
the media has a big part also of the situations
that you are in now.
Speaker 2: So lies on Fox two lies for internet.
Speaker 6: It doesn't stop.
If you thought it might become better, then
Biden wins.
And now Biden is president for a year, but
nothing changed.
Set up a town and.
I don't see any thing regarding heating, also
society, so society gets split more and more.
Do you see any way out of it?
Speaker 1: Well, unfortunately, if anybody
thought Joe Biden being president would reduce
the lies in media, I expected the lies to
go up.
Speaker 2: And of course they
Speaker 1: have, and that's exactly
Speaker 2: the way that that I
Speaker 1: expected it to go.
But we don't, you know, here's the thing we
fundamentally don't have a system that encourages
or favors healing in the way that you're talking
about because it requires no one putting partizanship
aside.
Speaker 2: And I mean, I'm Partizan
Speaker 1: in saying this, but to heal, we
would need everybody to say, Hey, you know
what?
That Trump experiment?
That was a disaster.
We can never do that again.
We were globally humiliated under Trump, as
if we just we just can't.
But that's my Partizan view, and someone else
would say, No,
Speaker 2: no, no, David, you're right.
Speaker 1: You're just wrong about that.
That's not what the healing is going to come
from.
So we can't even get agreement as to what
would cause the
Speaker 2: healing to take place.
So there's a couple of different
Speaker 1: topics in there that you mentioned.
They're all good, but unfortunately, everything
is exactly as I expected.
The media lies have escalated with Joe Biden.
The partizanship is
Speaker 2: certainly not diminishing
Speaker 1: and even uncontroversial things
that Joe Biden wants to do like an infrastructure
plan are now being seen by the right as these
radical communist ideas,
Speaker 2: which of course, they're not.
Speaker 6: Oh, yes.
The problem is, I don't see any way out of
it again.
So the next elections might be the last.
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, I don't that's that's
very dark.
The next elections might be
Speaker 2: the last, but I share
Speaker 1: your concern about growing
Speaker 2: authoritarianism for sure.
Speaker 1: I am right there with you, Tobias.
Speaker 6: Okay.
See also question if I get time for sure.
It might be a bit polemic, but it's about
this line between being bad in your truck,
being a bad president, not doing your duty
and treason.
What I mean and specific,
Speaker 2: as Donald loves
Speaker 6: to have people being upset set
helps him.
And he saw a chance in using code not to get
people upset.
He politicizes co-owner.
Which leads to many that people instead of
helping American people, he is killing them
for his, yeah, for his own good.
And isn't there some there a line that it's
going to treason?
Speaker 2: Yeah, there
Speaker 1: is a line.
I don't know what the line is, but I think
it's important to mention Trump's handling
of coronavirus.
Even if he thought it would be
Speaker 2: good for him, it wasn't
Speaker 1: good.
Leaders that handled the pandemic
Speaker 2: well got reelected.
Trump lost,
Speaker 1: and I believe that if Trump had
handled the pandemic well, he would have won.
So the one area I disagree with you is,
Speaker 2: I think Trump
Speaker 1: may have calculated pretending
there's no pandemic is going to help me.
It backfired, and it might be responsible
for why he lost.
Speaker 4: They are good, but people are dead.
Speaker 1: I know I know it doesn't help the
people who died.
No, there's no question but but from from
the political argument you were making.
Tobias, thank you.
Great to hear from you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right, there is Tobias from Germany.
We're going to take a very quick break.
If you're holding.
Don't hang up because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment.